- [Woman] You know, you
gentlemen are up there,
do you think women can
be the same as you guys
sitting up there, saying
things the same way
and be accepted in the same way?
- No. And I think that sucks but
I've thought about this a lot.
I've thought about
this a crap load.
I invested in Birchbox.
I wrote the first check
into that company
and I sat in the pitch in
Starbucks and said
yes in 12 minutes.
And they got super pumped
and emotional in a good way.
Not in a cliché bullshit
like women way
just like pumped.
And I asked them I was like
I couldn't put my finger on it
and they're like, "We've gotten
60 no's in a row,
"You're our first yes."
And I was cool and I didn't
really think much of it.
It was the nicest day,
early in the spring
it was the nicest day of
the year four years ago.
The first nice day, you know
that awesome day that
we love so much in New York.
So I was like I'm gonna
walk home 'cause
I was kinda in midtown,
I was going to Upper East Side.
Somewhere around
eight blocks in I was like,
"Huh. I really wonder that
idea was so obvious
"I really wonder if those were
two dudes would they
"get 11 yes's instead of one?"
You have to understand,
and this is not even close,
my mom, my wife and
my first-born daughter
are my life. Right?
I love my bro and
my dad and all this
but that is my world
and I, if God, you know
I actually don't care
if my daughter, god willing,
would want to be a
big time entrepreneur and CEO
I would want her to
dominate the world
and I think that people
want to look at the world
through rosy glasses
or very cynical glasses.
And I think the answer is
always in-between.
There's a million
women entrepreneurs
or storytellers that
are killing it. Right?
We have to recognize that the
way the market consumes
people is different based
on if they're a woman,
if they're African-American,
if they're Muslim-American,
just a million.
How about pretty?
How about just being pretty?
Versus not being
as pretty. Right?
There's a million variables in
play and I think it's insane.
I come from the Soviet Union.
Right? Where everything being
the same is the game.
It's just not real. Right?
By the way, it doesn't
mean that it's worse,
it doesn't mean
that it's worse at all.
It just means that it's different.
So is it the same?
No, it's not the same.
'Cause everybody's gonna
consume it differently.
It's also not the same for each,
you're an African-American woman
the way that you're consuming me
is different than those
two Russian guys over there
who have a connection point
with me that's different.
I think this whole notion
of is it the same,
of course it's not.
It's a silly question.
I think what's more important is
I'm a big believer of
betting on your strengths
and I spoke to it earlier.
Again, I won the
lotto completely.
White male in America
and born in the Soviet Union.
I won triple big.
I think that we have to
understand how things work.
But I'll tell you that,
how about this
Casey and I did a video
together the other day
Casey's fanbase hated me
as a net score because I talked
over him during the show.
'Cause I get hyper
and this and that.
And I went into my own channel
and had to apologize
to like 500 people that came
over from Casey's world
and said, "GaryVee, fuck you.
You suck shit."
(laughter)
Need to spend less time of
what we can't be and
we need to spend more
time on what we can be.